hablamos por supuesto también de salud
en directo américa de france 24 con más
romeros a la mar vamos a hablar de la
vacuna rusa sputnik que se ha visto
afectada por el conflicto el conflicto
entre rusia y ucrania
claro pues el rol de hecho hay pocas
esferas de la vida que ahora mismo no
estén afectadas por este conflicto sobre
todo también a raíz de las sanciones de
eeuu y de la unión europea contra varias
empresas rusas repasemos cómo es que han
están afectando esas sanciones a la
vacuna particularmente que se desarrolló
en rusia la vacuna tanto sputnik ue como
sputnik light que es la versión
monodosis fueron desarrolladas por el
instituto de investigación de amalia que
es un instituto que forma parte del
ministerio público de salud ruso pero
recibió la financiación del fondo ruso
para la inversión directa es un fondo
que se dedica a financiar iniciativas
empresariales en el país que nació con
dinero público de hecho auspiciado en
2011 por vladimir putin y también por
dimitri medvedev en ese momento el
presidente pero pues a raíz de la
invasión rusa por un lado la unión
europea ha prohibido participar en
proyectos donde se colabore con él fondo
ruso y eeuu también ha sancionado la
entidad diciendo que es una entidad de
fondos corruptos de las políticas
corruptas de putin y también además pues
sancionó a su director ejecutivo kiril
dimitir entonces así vamos a lo que nos
compete las consecuencias entonces de
estas sanciones sobre la vacuna pues por
ahora sólo lo podemos ir aventurando no
así el fondo por ejemplo queda
desfinanciado puede ser que sea difícil
proseguir con la investigación o que
incluso haya problemas de producción de
la vacuna pero hay otras consecuencias
de las sanciones muy palpables sobre
esta vacuna que tiene que ver con la
organización mundial de la salud la
vacuna todavía no ha sido aprobada por
la ms y pues la misma entidad ya ha
dicho que tendrá que retrasar todo su
proceso de evaluación de visita a las
instalaciones a raíz de este conflicto
así era como hablaba la entidad la la
organización mundial de la salud en una
rueda de prensa la semana pasada
íbamos a ir a hacer inspecciones en
rusia a partir del 7 de marzo pero esas
inspecciones se retrasaron para más
adelante
estos pesos
las revisiones se vieron afectadas por
la situación actual incluidos problemas
con las opciones de vuelos y las
tarjetas de crédito problemas en la
parte logística
estamos en conversaciones con los
aplicantes rusos y estableceremos nuevas
fechas lo antes posibles google
marco hemos usado la sputnik en nuestro
continente nuestra región américa latina
y caribe pues la verdad es que es una
región donde hay millones de personas
que se han vacunado con esta vacuna con
este fármaco ruso vamos a repasar los
países donde ha sido aprobada son la
mayoría de hecho de la región y también
aquí ven algunos de los que más dosis
pues han comprado estamos hablando de
argentina de méxico y por supuesto
también pues de venezuela no nos podemos
dar cuenta de hecho que hay mucha
geopolítica y mucha estrategia que rodea
la distribución de las vacunas por
ejemplo hay países de centroamérica que
fueron pues de los primeros en recibir y
estos fármacos igual que venezuela
también que al final es una muestra de
apoyo del gobierno ruso a este tipo de
gobiernos pero también un intento de
mostrarse como una alternativa a los
fármacos de eeuu y de europa que de
hecho fue una estrategia que al menos al
inicio funcionó porque pues recordemos
que argentina empezó vacunando con
sputnik eligió sputnik para poder
empezar sus campañas de vacunación
también pues con duras críticas al
acaparamiento de los gobiernos tanto
pues del mundo occidental del norte
global entonces pues digamos que fue una
especie de punta de lanza también de las
estrategias políticas del gobierno de
vladímir putin mar con todo esto que
está ocurriendo le pregunto si las
personas vacunadas en américa latina'
con este fármaco con sputnik puede haber
consecuencias claro vayamos un momento a
lo práctico no de nuevo es difícil
saberlo pero es una posibilidad que haya
problemas con las vacunaciones de la
vacuna sputnik y de sputnik light sin
embargo tampoco es que sean problemas
que no existían antes por un lado con el
tema de la aprobación por la
organización mundial de la salud ya han
habido problemas para que estas personas
puedan viajar porque hay muchos países
que solo aceptan las personas
inmunizadas con las vacunas aprobadas
por la ms pero es que además ha habido
una carga de desconfianza sobre este
fármaco por problemas de entregas de
cumplir los plazos sobre todo con las
segundas dosis no es que expone que no
sea eficaz aquí en este momento pues su
eficacia científica no es lo que estamos
debatiendo de hecho lo es es una de las
que más más eficaz es pero la
organización mundial de la salud también
busca pues calidad calidad en la
producción en la información técnica y
es ahí donde es donde ha habido
problemas sin embargo pues para dar un
poco de tranquilidad a estas soluciones
ya se han podido encontrar antes por
ejemplo argentino a guatemala ya
empezaron a vacunar con segundas dosis
de otras vacunas y en enero se publicó
un estudio que aseguraba pues que se
puede vacunar con segunda dosis de rn
mensajero es cuando se ha recibido una
primera dosis después de que entonces
digamos que en los sanitarios en lo de
salud y en lo que cuenta en lo que
respecta a la inmunización podemos estar
tranquilos bueno estamos tranquilos con
eso pero más allá de lo técnico que ya
lo conversamos tiene esto una
repercusión sobre la imagen
internacional de rusia marc pues habrá
algo de lastre aunque ahora mismo es
difícil que eso empeore al menos en el
mundo occidental rusia tuvo mucha mucha
prisa en desarrollar esta vacuna no era
una de estos como decíamos una de su
punta de lanza y fue sputnik la primera
vacuna aprobada contra el cubit 19no un
intento de hacer una vacuna ams que
además fuera más barata que la de
moderna o que la de facer también con
esa imagen pues de que rusia iba a ser
quien iba a ayudar a los países que
estaban teniendo dificultades en acceder
a los fármacos sin embargo como vemos
eso no ha funcionado tan bien tanto por
la ms como los problemas de producción
pero es que además ha habido
desconfianza dentro de la propia rusia
para vacunarse con el fármaco
desarrollada por sus propias
instituciones y eso de qué nos habla
pues de una cierta desconfianza en el
gobierno que ahora mismo además también
sale tanto a relucir con el conflicto
actual no hubieron reportes sobre gente
que no quería vacunarse con sputnik pues
porque desconfiaba de esa vacuna es una
lástima también porque en momentos de
crisis lo que debería primar raúl es la
posibilidad de poder confiar los unos en
los otros no olvidemos que estamos en
una plena crisis sanitaria que
deberíamos pues colaborar para de
solucionarla mar gracias como siempre
por toda esta información vamos